it's impossible for me to imagine that
10 years from now
somebody is going to say i love aws i
just wish it were a little less reliable
i'm going through and teaching myself
neural networks and you know
doing the same thing with machine
learning and gans and this and that
because ai is going to have more of an
impact
than the internet did i worked on
mindset for myself and i'm such a
believer in mindset is almost everything
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level of
genius at
something so today let's live your best
belief life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one build stable strategies with jeff
bezos
i very frequently get the question
what's going to change in the next 10
years and
that is an interesting question it's a
very common one i almost
never get the question what's not going
to change
in the next 10 years and i submit to you
that that second question is actually
the more important of the two
because you can build a business
strategy
around the things that are stable in
time and so as you pointed out in our
retail business
we know that customers want low prices
and i know that's going to be true 10
years from now they want fast delivery
they want vast selection it's impossible
to imagine a future 10 years from now
where a customer comes up to me and says
jeff i love amazon i just wish the
prices were a little higher
you know how you i love amazon i just
wish you delivered a little more slowly
impossible and so the effort that we put
into those
things spinning those things up
we know the energy we put into it today
will still be paying dividends for our
customers 10 years from now
and so those when you have something
that you know is true
even over the long term you can afford
to put a lot of energy into it
on aws the big ideas
are also pretty straightforward it's
impossible for me to imagine
that ten years from now somebody is
going to say i love aws
i just wish it were a little less
reliable
or i love aws i just wish you would
raise
prices it should be a little more
expensive
or i love aws and i wish you would
innovate and improve the apis at a
slightly slower rate
none of those things you can imagine and
so
the big ideas in business are often very
obvious but it's very hard to maintain a
firm grasp
of the obvious at all times but if you
can do that
and continue to spin up those flywheels
and put energy into those
things as we're doing with aws over time
you build a better and better service
for your customers on the things that
genuinely matter to them
rule number two always keep learning
with mark cuban
now i'm going through and teaching
myself neural networks and you know
doing the same thing with machine
learning and gans and this and that
because ai is going to have more of an
impact
than the internet did ai plus new types
of chipsets
plus 5g is going to change things far
more than we've ever seen
anything change and understanding where
and how to apply it
is going to be critical but just as
important knowing how to sep
segregate and separate the [ __ ]
right is as important because
every email you are about to send me is
going to say
i have this ai solution and we're using
algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if i
didn't do that work
if i didn't sit down and do the aws
machine learning tutorials if i didn't
go on youtube and take
you know the nyu introduction to neural
networks or whatever
i'm not going to know it i'm not going
to be able to apply it and i'm not going
to be able to be first
and that's fun that's fun knowing i get
to kick the ass to some 22 year old nyu
graduate that's awesome rule number
three take advantage of the
internet with elon musk and think about
the various problems
that we were facing or what would most
likely change the future
um the when they were in college there
were five things that i thought would be
um i mean
i thought these were actually these
these i would not regard this as a
profound insight but rather an obvious
one
uh the the internet would fundamentally
change humanity because it's it's like
uh humanity will become more of a super
organism
because the internet is like the nervous
like nervous system
um now suddenly any part of the human
human organisms anywhere would have
access to all the information
amazing instantly zero link hey well
like imagine if you didn't have a
nervous system
you wouldn't know what's going on your
fingers wouldn't know what's going on
your toes wouldn't know what's going on
it you'd have to do it by diffusion
um and yeah and the way information used
to work was really by diffusion one
human would have to call another human
or or write them yes like if it was a
letter
you would have to write like you'd have
to have that letter to another human
that would
be carried through a bunch of things
find another person would give it to you
extremely slow diffusion um
and if you wanted access to books if
you're not did not have a library you're
not you don't have it that's it so
um now you have access to all the books
instantly
um and you you if you can be
in a remote like you know mountaintop
jungle location or something and have
access to
all of humanity's information if you've
got a link to the internet this was a
fundamental profound change
rule number four have a morning routine
with grant cardone
is there any daily disciplines that you
have in your life daily routines
that you would attribute to your success
uh yeah i try to beat the sun up
i write my goals down every day and i
try to get i try to hit the gym
so i don't do it perfect every day sure
some things throw me off and and um
you know unfortunately i have a i
created a lifestyle where
where some things are taking care for me
that that
that um most people don't have that that
option you know somebody drives the kids
to school i don't have to do that that
would change everything
if i had to do that who knows maybe i
need to maybe i need to start driving
the kids to school it seems like a
complete waste of time to me
but um i live two two minutes from my
office
uh so when i bounce out of here i gotta
go do a live a live stream on real
estate but
but uh yeah that that's the first three
things if i can get that done in the
morning man i know i'm gonna have a good
day
yeah pretty simple to beat the sun up
make sure you write down your goals
yeah make sure you take care of yourself
get the blood flow and get the heart
pumping yeah and i
goes down fresh a new unit like in a new
unit of time like i've written down
today like i had never written them down
before
nice yeah that's um so
so so simple on the outside but so many
people won't do
so i dare i dare everybody listening
here
to try to do it for 30 days in a row see
if you can even make seven
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five delegate with bill gates
it's been a lot of fun you know there's
tons of things that i'm not good at and
so the question is always can i get
somebody
involved you know you know certain
day-to-day management things
negotiating things political things
scientific experts who really do
have the time to focus in on one thing
like i did in in my twenties
and just really really see all the the
possibilities
rule number six solve a problem with
jamie kern lima
sometimes it's like god has other plans
it's like something hits you and you
don't even know
and well frankly the things going
through my mind were
what's you know what's what's going on
what's wrong with me
uh uh i would try i would spend my
makeup trying to cover it up because
rosacea's bright red and you get these
um
patches on your skin and they're
textured like sandpaper like a rush
right almost
yes and it's very textured and so um
no i mean i think any time you know
something happens to us whether it's
a physical thing a physical change an
emotional
situation something with our health
right anytime we have something like
that
you know the the it's hard to go through
the
the beginning of it because i struggled
a little bit honestly i had thoughts
like
okay am i pretty anymore like just those
things like i'm embarrassed
never even said that out loud by the way
but like that's the truth i just
started doubting myself i started um
doubting okay is this gonna affect my
career you know
but in in the midst of the the start of
kind of that that
i guess struggle of going okay my
physical appearance is changing
let me wrap my head around this um uh
is when i started really looking into
makeup and and trying everything out
there spending my tiny paycheck on
on uh every product i could get my hands
on from the most expensive to
least expensive and and there's that
famous saying like
you know sometimes we make our mess our
message and that's sort of what happened
it was this entrepreneurial moment where
i realized there's nothing out there
that works for me right nothing that
will solve my problem
and there must be so many other people
that have just given up on makeup
because it doesn't work for them and
it's like
okay nothing works and and
the more i researched i'm like wow
seventy percent of women have
hyperpigmentation
wow all of us yeah yeah that's like oh
you know what i mean and
so many of us deal with just all
different uh things hormonal changes
everything acne and so i just thought
you know what
if i can solve this problem for me i
know that it could be
you know of service and life-changing
for for other people
also and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is change your mindset with sarah
blakely
banks started way before i cut the feet
out of my pantyhose
that's the sound bite in the press that
everybody's talked about for almost 20
years
but it actually started fundamentally on
when i was 16 i worked on mindset for
myself and i'm such a believer in
mindset is almost everything
and it just happened to be a set of
circumstances i was riding my bike with
one of my best friends
at 16 and she was run over by a car and
killed in front of me
and then a few months later my dad left
home and my parents separated and
ultimately got divorced
and when my dad moved out he came into
my bedroom and he handed me a cassette
tape series called how to be a no limit
person by wayne dyer
and he said sweetie i wish i discovered
this when i was your age instead of the
age of 40
and then he moved out and so i started
listening
to this how to be a no limit person
which was talking about visualization
law of attraction um not caring about
what other people think about you
the fear you know not being consumed by
the fear of failure
and it just the clouds parted for me and
i thought you know
i've spent a lot of time being taught
what to think but no one's really
teaching me how to think
and at 16 that was so incredibly
important so
in this digital platform it's kind of
passing on a lot of these insights
that deal with mindset that i think is
the real reason that spanx exists
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
percent
isn't enough we gotta do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following will jump
to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps in 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you i actually think you should
think
twice before starting certain types of
businesses so i think um
there are probably too many bad
businesses getting started and not
enough good ones
so that's it's um you know i don't think
there's i don't think there's anything
about
entrepreneurship per se that is um
that is is good you know i was telling
one of my friends a few years ago i was
asking him
what do you want to be doing in five or
ten years oh it's really clear i want to
be an entrepreneur
that's like saying i want to be rich i
want to be famous
um and i i don't think uh i don't think
those are good things being rich and
famous um they're not good as direct
goals
like if you if you have that as your
sole goal
you're unlikely to i think really really
succeed
and so i think you become an
entrepreneur because you're working on
an important problem nobody else is
working on
i think you should start a business if
you have uh something
if you're if you're working on a problem
that otherwise would not get solved
you don't need 150 iq to do what i do
thank god
you know you don't need 140 you know 135
you may need 115 or something like that
and
and but you do need discipline you have
to wait
until you see the fat pitch to swing at
because
investing is a no-call strike game you
know if i were a baseball player
and i only like pitches two inches above
my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get called out on strikes in
baseball you have to
you have to swing at pitches that you
you don't even necessarily like
particularly after the count gets to two
strikes
in business you don't have to swing at
anything you can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 or
it says general electric at 115 or so
general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but it's a marvelous game to be
in because there are no called strikes
and you can simply wait
for that one time in a month or six
months or a year
or two or three years when you really
know what you're doing where you like
the price
where you like the people running the
business and then you swing and you only
need a few swings in your lifetime
the hardest thing for me early on was
you know because i i just started off as
i was i was an engineer or you know i
wasn't even really an engineer as a
student
right it's i i thought i was going to be
an engineer when i graduated
and you know when you're when you're
building something yourself
you kind of have all the meetings in
your head right it's like you don't need
to articulate the principles so clearly
it's like you kind of can make all the
trade-offs on
on everything from architecture to
product to marketing to you know just
all these things and
you're kind of just you have the context
to trade this off
and i think it's really easy
when you start building something to
um to underestimate
how much context you need to put out
there and how clear you need to be about
what you're trying to do so
you know most of my mistakes early on in
building the company
were about not being clear enough
internally about what we were trying to
do and there's this very famous
episode where where like
in 2006 a couple years into building the
company
yahoo tried to buy us and so they
offered a ton of money
and a lot of the people who who i'd
hired at the point they were kind of
experienced
technology executives and this was like
all of their startup dream
come true right they joined and then you
know within you know a year or a few
months like the
the company had the opportunity to exit
for this large amount of money
and you know i really
failed through that period to
communicate what we were trying to do
and what we
what we stood for and
in the absence of that that context
then of course it was a rational thing
for people to think that this was like a
good outcome for us to have
your company anticipated the financial
crisis
managed your clients funds through that
period
make the argument that your culture
actually has something to do with that
result
well first of all i think that
well tell you what the moment was like
we you do our calculations and
uh we have a view that's very different
than the rest of the world's view at
that time
so the independent thinking we had among
ourselves different people who had
different views and the ability to work
ourselves through those um
was essential for us to being able to
stand upside from the crowd so i needed
to have the independent thinking and we
needed to work
it through and then even at that time we
had to have
the fear of being wrong because you can
never be confident that you're wrong
right in the markets and so to place the
bet but to place the bet
in a defensive way and to work out
together
the engineering what what i believe is
that everything happens over and over
again
through history world operates like a
machine it happens over and over again
and that
if you can sort of go above yourself and
your circumstances
and look down at yourself within your
circumstances within a historical
perspective
and then have agreed upon principles
you know principles are how to handle
things that happen over and over again
by having that um it's helpful and ours
are
just oriented around this idea of
meritocracy so
it allowed us to have an independent
point of view while being
not 100 certain and you know to be
defensive and
it allowed us to play that well what
advice would you have
for managers or companies that are
really working through change and
struggling
let me uh define creative destruction
or i will use uh schumpeter's
definition here's the way he put it it
is not
price and output competition which
counts but the competition
from the new product the new technology
the new source of supply the new type of
organization
which commands a decisive cost or
quality advantage
and which strikes not at the margins
of the prophets and the outputs but at
their foundations
and their very lives so that's what
we're talking about here this is
not life or death for us individually
but life and death
for our businesses and our jobs and so
what we do
to communicate this is get all our
employees to understand
that change is a risk for all of us
but not changing isn't a risk
it's suicide it is a certainty
that you are going out of business and
you are going to if you
individual employee if you're not
changing and improving
and working on that every day you're not
going to have your job
whereas if you take what you think are
risks and you find
a way to eliminate most of your job
because there's a way to do this more
efficiently or to bypass
do it a completely different way here at
coke you're not going to
lose your job you're going to be a hero
i don't agree
that you should narrow your focus
what i believe is that you get the best
outcome when you make the broadest
appeal
in terms of leadership and excitement
and so forth and we worked very hard to
make that happen
but there were there were other things
for example we would refuse to do
exclusive deals with people but i would
explain to people well
we don't really do exclusive deals but
we only have the capacity to work with
one and it's going to be you
right so that there are other ways of
achieving those kinds of things
so i'd be careful to to conclude that
you should do a small thing
all success starts from doing one thing
really really well
but you'll recruit better with a broader
vision that's credible and that you can
articulate but go back to that
selling the dream right what you do is
selling a dream if you can't sell the
dream then you're not going to be
successful
it's more difficult to run a business
because in the past you could make a
decision had some time to work it out
fix it change it build a constituency
demonstrate your wisdom and today we
want
instant gratification you've got to know
is it going to work and then we're going
to ten thousand emails
20 seconds later so that's it's not
working it's like complaining about i
have an iphone 6.
and iphone is just an amazing device
and people are complaining if you sit on
it it bends
now if i took a mac computer and threw
it out of a
five-story window it would break
okay so what i mean we just
we we don't have any tolerance
everybody's a talking head everybody's
got an idea
and and one of the problems in life is
sort of sorting out
what is realistic what is real what is
factual
uh what is put in context and social
media
isn't designed to do that social media
is designed to let everybody talk to
everybody all the time
and to me that means you have to have
the old values we don't have to teach
our kids to code as much as we have to
teach them to read to write to do
arithmetic
to understand how that numbers are just
another language and how to
speak that language that you're going to
have to work collaboratively and
collectively
and you're not going to turn this all
over to technology and if you do
nobody's going to have a job
when i was 16 i i got this job
working for a newspaper in houston
and my job was to sell subscriptions to
the paper
on the telephone and um
i realized uh two uh
things when i was doing this i realized
that
people that were buying the newspaper
generally had two things in common
either they were moving to a new
residence
or they were getting married and
uh it turns out that you could go find
information about both of those things
in enormous quantities so in the state
that i lived in
in texas when you get it when you want
to get a marriage license you have to
file
with the state and it's public
information
particularly the address that you want
the license sent to once it's issued
so i hired all my friends and went to
every county in the surrounding 16
counties in houston
captured the addresses of all the people
that applied for marriage licenses
and sent them a direct mail offer to
offer them the newspaper for a free
trial and then a subscription
and you know ended up making a making a
fair
sum of money for for a teenager oh my
son learning how to skateboard
you you were talking about dropping in
oh gosh me sure that
yeah that don't remind me that's a very
painful part of my uh
part of my past no it's true my this was
i don't know maybe five years ago six
years ago because my son
he's pretty passionate about it i mean
passionate enough that we
built a huge half pipe in the in the
backyard
and of course you want to do things with
your kids
and so i wanted to learn how to
skateboard and then one of those
fundamental things you learn in
skateboarding is that
there's that act called dropping in
where you're standing on the edge of the
half pipe and you've got to drop forward
and
roll down that slope but it's something
that if you hesitate
if you lean back if you hedge your bets
you are
guaranteed to end up in your ass and the
only
only way to do it is to fully commit to
lean
forward to put all your weight in that
front foot and down you go
but what did your son tell you about
leaning too far forward
oh i think he said that no one ever
leans too far forward
that it's impossible to lean too far
forward that whatever your mind is
saying this is too far forward
you're still probably too far backwards
in other words
don't worry about it go for it commit i
apologize in advance for the sports
reference
but i would say get in the weight room
the weight room of life
what do you do in a weight room if
you're an athlete
or a kind of retired senior citizen like
me
you prepare you prepare
you build new capabilities you get
stronger
you get faster you figure out how to get
leverage and yet in your business lives
those are precisely the right messages
one of the things that i think has made
microsoft the company that is today
is that we weren't afraid to get in the
weight room
in the late 80s we had plenty of
customers
investors tell us we would quote never
be an
enterprise company today
many people think the bulk of the 350
billion of value in microsoft
is in our enterprise business we weren't
afraid to sit there even before we had
it figured out
and just work to prepare to get better
to build
new capabilities and whether we're
talking about what you need to do for
your startup
for the hospital that you join or for
yourself
personally you have to build new
capabilities
new quickness and new leverage somebody
taught me a long time ago
a very valuable lesson which is if you
do the right things on the top line
the bottom line will follow and what
they meant by that was
if you get the right strategy if you
have the right people
and if you have the right culture
culture at your company
you'll do the right products you'll do
the right marketing you'll do the right
things logistically in manufacturing and
distribution
and if you do all those things right the
bottom line will follow
what i learned going to beauty salon and
asking them after the news director had
told me that my hair was too thick and
my
eyes were too far apart and i needed a
makeover and um
sitting in a beauty salon in a french
beauty salon allowing them to put a
french perm on my black hair
and having the perm burn through my
cerebral cortex
and not being the woman that i am now so
not having the courage to say
this is burning me
and coming out a week later bald and
having to go on the air
you learn a lot about yourself when
you're black and a woman involved and
trying to be an anchor woman
you learn you learn you're not diana
ross
and that you're not barbara walters
trying to be i was at the time
i had a lot of lessons i remember going
on the air many times and
not reading my copy ahead of time and i
was on the air one night and
ran across the word b-a-r-b-a-d-o-s
that may be barbados to you but it was
barbados to me that night
and telling the story as an anchor woman
about a vote
in abstentia california i thought it was
located near san francisco
and one of the worst one of the worst
this is one i broke out of my barber
shell because i'm sitting there crossing
my legs trying to talk like barbara be
like barbara
and uh i was reading a story about
someone with a
blaze attitude which
if i had gone to wellesley i would have
known it was blase
and i started to laugh at myself on the
air and broke through my barbara shell
and had decided on that day that
laughing was okay even though barbara
hadn't
at that time
and it was through my series of mistakes
that i learned that i could be a better
oprah than i could be a better barber
and i allowed barbara to be the mentor
for me
as she always has been and i decided
then
to try to pursue the idea of being
myself and i am just thrilled that i get
paid so much every day for just
just being myself but it was a lesson
long in coming
that i had the instinct that the inner
voice
that told me that you need to try to
find a way
to answer to your own truth was the
voice i needed to be still
and listen to get this this is just
remember this because this will happen
many times your life
when people show you who they are
believe them the first time
not the 29th time
[Applause]
that's particularly good when it comes
to to men's situations
because when he doesn't call back the
first time
when you're mistreated the first time
when you see someone who shows you a
lack of integrity or dishonesty
the first time know that that will be
followed
by many many many other times that will
at some point in life come back to haunt
or hurt you
when people show you who they are
believe them
the first time live your life from a
point of view of truth and you will
live your life from truth and you will
survive
everything everything i believe even
death
you will survive everything if you can
live your life from a point of view of
truth
up till 2002 all we focused on was
survival
and then once we got public and and
we're profitable we started thinking wow
this thing might last
and the the cruelest irony would be to
not want to work there
um you know to let it become a place we
didn't want to be and so we tried to
think through what do we really care
about
realize what we really care about is
working with incredible people on hard
problems
and that that was the essence so we
should organize everything around
supporting that
of working with you know just incredibly
talented people and so that led us to
freedom and responsibility because
incredible people don't want to be
micromanaged
and the idea is that we manage through
setting context
and letting people run and you've got to
have the right people you've got to
reinforce that with values
setting context about what the company
is trying to achieve
but the idea is to build a system where
amazing amounts of
service improvement happen in the
marketing and the content
in the technology and the user interface
without direct intervention of meat
and so some companies operate by you
know the product genius at the top and
we all know
these companies and this whole motif of
you know to be a great ceo you've got to
be the great
product person who really you know and
it's intoxicating and fun
but you're building incredible amounts
of dependence on yourself
and eventually you know how well i know
how turkish consumers consume netflix
it's not that well and so you're much
stronger obviously building a
distributed
set of great thinkers people know that
but in the past what they've done
is try to make everything a process they
said okay i don't want it to be a genius
so we're going to organize a process for
everything
and these once in a while you heard
we're going to dummy proof it it's going
to be such a good process that anybody
this was the ibm thing
and then if you dummy proof the process
you only get dummies to work
there you know to do the process and so
that's why
we're so you know opposed to that
instead so focused on giving people
great freedom realizing there'll be
mistakes
but there'll be a lot of positive
achievement too can you give some
examples
of that i mean you know you talk about
it generically it sounds great but what
are some specific examples i i take
pride in making as few decisions as
possible
as opposed to as many as possible and so
when something significant changes in
the content or
the house of cards purchase you know ted
explained it it was a huge purchase at
that time
it was a half an hour conversation you
know we went back and forth i said are
you really sure it's a great bet yes
let's do it
you know it wasn't like me reading the
script and me meeting with kevin spacey
and you know
or uh equivalent samples on the
marketing more equivalent examples on
um the product and the evolution there
so it's creating a sense of
i want to make a difference and i can
make a difference and if that's what the
leader
gets excited about is that other people
are making a difference and you've got
the right people
you got to be super demanding so the you
know one part is freedom and
responsibility
the other part is a high performance
culture where we say adequate
performance gets a generous severance
package
and so you know we look at it we say we
want to be like a major league baseball
team
and you know you've only got so many
positions on the field and if everyone
is not
incredible at what they do then you're
not going to win
so you turn over a lot of people and so
we turn over a lot of people we feel
like
you know we give people a fair shot um
and
you know we we hire pretty openly and
they know what they're getting into
but we're looking for people who for
whom freedom and responsibility work
i came here to share with you the
entrepreneur's spirit the dreams
this is what i learned from the other
part of the world i learned from the
american dreams
i learned from many other startups in
the whole world
that the stream of how they do it i
think the very important
is that making sure your dream can be
realized
making sure your dream makes steps by
step
every week every month and making sure
that
your employees believe in making sure
your customers are happy
because your if your customer happy your
employees are happy
the shareholder will be happy do not try
to spend a lot of time with your
shareholders
spend enough time with your customers
spend enough time with your employees
and even do not spend a lot of time with
the competitors
because you are we are all so early
stage
the best way to compete to fight against
your competitor
is your customers it's your colleagues
and i think for all of you there are
many areas
uh where there's leverage available in
the world where you know one or two
people
a good idea a lot of hard work can
really make a difference there's many
many things like that
and it's good not to forget that but
it's good to look for those things
google's mission is to organize the
world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful
and one of the things that surprised me
that's a very broad mission it's a lot
of work
we're not going to achieve it anytime
soon right
it's almost an impossible task but it's
an exciting task and one that you can
get other people
excited about and they can help you
and one of the things that all surprised
me is sometimes easier to do something
that's harder because other people get
excited about it and you can get much
more resource
you can get tremendous resources to
solve a hard problem whereas you might
only get minor resources to solve a
small problem
the way that we operate as a company
you know especially in dangote is like
what i said
we have a vision that vision will have a
strategy of how we are going to achieve
the vision which we do normally over a
period of
five years you know i mean like today uh
we know where we are going even this
investment that i announced or 400
million dollars
here i didn't just sit down on my own
and just
say it it is part of our strategic plan
to invest in kenya during my california
springs and summers
i spent most of my days in the high
sierras in yosemite valley
working as a river guide and a rock
climbing instructor
i loved those jobs but unfortunately
they didn't pay that well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley i had learned a program
in college
i didn't love programming but it was fun
and i was good at it and computer
program programming gave me the same
kind of satisfaction
as solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life i thought i was
making real progress on my journey of
self-discovery
i had found a cause i had a couple of
jobs that i love
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing
foolish things she wanted me to work
full time as a computer programmer
or go back to college and finish my
degree
we compromised sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember
was a sailing class taught at berkeley
marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said this was the single
stupidest idea
she had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out and then she divorced
me
[Music]
this was a pivotal moment in my life
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time i was not disappointed in
myself
for failing to be the person they
thought i
should be their dreams
and my dreams were different
i would never confuse the two of them
again
you've made ginormous amounts money
what do you guys plan on doing the rest
of your life you've achieved so much
already
i think you know there are many
important things to life uh
you know aside from financial or career
success
uh and in fact uh it's not necessarily
the ultimate
success that motivates you it's the
process of getting there and the uh
technologies or products that you build
or in whatever realms you may be in so
i'm not too concerned about finding
something to do
though i do think it'll be based on
doing things that i really enjoy
and not have some end goal in mind
if you want seven more awesome rules for
how billionaires think check out the
video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there that's not really
how it works if you don't love it
don't expect others will either your
relationship with time
is such a key component of your life
because when you get caught in a routine
time goes so quickly